we're in trouble when he retires you
know it being 1:00 I call to order the
Department of Health and Human Services
oversight committee and as rollover
chairman from last time and also first
named on the
announcement um I call on representative
Edwards for a nomination for chairman uh
thank you for recognizing me Mr chair I
would like to place into nomination
representative Mark Pearson to be the
chair in the coming term do we have a a
second thank you uh any other
nominations then all in
favor opposed thank you uh I would like
to appoint uh representative Lucy Weber
as
clerk we should have before us the draft
minutes um in a band for now um we do
have or should have in front of us the
minutes of the meeting of oversight for
November 22nd you were emailed this
we'll give you a minute or two to find
it and uh vote to approve I'm sorry vote
to
approve Senator gray moves to approve
the minutes do we have a second second
representative Edwards seconds and we'll
Mr chair just uh for your information I
did speak to the aid for Senator avard
and he was called away on a business
emergency I know on his business often
times pipes break and he is needed uh
but I don't have all the
details thank you for that so that is an
excused
absence and uh representative Jessica
lontine uh is an alternate and she has
an excused absence cor she was only
named recently and is preparing for her
mother's 90th birthday celebration
tomorrow the other alternate has not yet
been named uh in the defense of the
speaker's office they got approximately
750,000 uh bills coming their way which
had to be assigned to the appropriate
committees and they're working 12-hour
days seven days a week and are getting
minutes all right all in favor I opposed
sorry Senator Rosen Wald abstains
because she wasn't here which is very
very good and representative Woods for
the same reason for the same reason
correct remember that advice I gave you
when you told me you weren't going to
run for the house again save your lawn
signs you will be back welcome back
thank you kindly sir you welcome uh DHHS
thank you so much you have not you do
not have the commissioner today so you
have the the JB team my name is Patricia
Tilly I'm an associate commissioner with
the Department of Health and Human
Services and I got the big chair I know
and I'm Chris santinello I'm also an
associate commissioner so thank you for
having us today yes you want to start
sure I'll get us started um I think John
gave you a little PowerPoint such as
that we actually wanted to talk a little
bit about a problem yes it is um about a
problem um area for both of our
respective staff that Trish and I both
have um and that would be the staff of
the Bureau of Developmental Services
DCF um primarily and um it was a problem
area for both of our staff teams and we
really want to talk a little bit about
how they work together um to solve it to
improve quality for the customer
experience
um and transition to The Adult Services
System um from DCF shouldn't be a
surprise right because it's based most
of the times on an age whether you're 22
21 18 it doesn't just happen overnight
um but yet our teams were struggling
with that whole process and so um it
really wasn't viewed externally because
they would scramble they would get it
done but it really wasn't done in the
smoothest of ways um and it really
wasn't best practice or sustainable so
luckily Trisha and I work really well
together and when our teams came to us
and said this isn't working we want to
make it better um we sat down with them
and really talked about the problem and
they were eager to work together but
neither team had the capacity to pull it
together and so um we sat down they
actually identified that we also need to
bring in the Bureau of assistants
because they handle eligibility and so
because we have a few big tables at the
department everybody sat down together
and really what helped was bringing
everybody together into one room and
using a Kaizen event um we're able to
identify currently what are we
doing what do we what are our shared
roles what are our responsibilities
under statute process um that they work
under and what what are the barriers
that we're facing um but then they also
set a vision for the future what should
this really be like for Children and
Families sure so um we were able to do
this internally which is another thing
that we wanted to highlight we have a
number of Staff in our department who've
been trained in our black belt lean
partners and do these Kaizen events and
so we actually brought in folks from
public health I I called on my old
friends in public health and I said you
know how to think about problems and we
have two groups and even probably a
little bit more probably three groups of
people that all mean really well but
they all know their Lane of work so why
don't we bring in someone who has
complete fresh eyes um and to say let's
let's map this out so they came in with
all of their sticky notes and all of the
large paper and what you'll see right
here that you can't really read and we
just put in here for illustration is we
mapped out this incredibly complex
system where you have um work with our
area agent gencies in the community you
have work with DCF again these are youth
that are um have significant
disabilities that are in the care and
custody of DCF and need to move into an
adult system and um we were working with
our folks over at BFA Works working with
Folks at developmental Services again
getting them in the same room and
literally mapping out the swim Lanes of
who does what when so that it doesn't uh
we don't repeat what we had seen in the
past which which was really well-meaning
people calling each other on the phone L
sending an email and time would slip
away and so we got out the big paper we
got them in the room we pulled this out
and we identified a couple of areas of
bottlenecks of where decisions needed to
be made we clarified in the room who
makes what decision when all of this is
also you know we're switching kiddos
into adult Medicaid as well so many
levers need to be pulled that we now
actually have a Playbook on how to do it
when in the past it was just done on
personal relationships there would be
someone who knew how to do this and you
just depended on them so we went through
we mapped it all out and where we are
now is that we have a consistent process
it's not complete yet we have a map we
know what to do the work but what we've
embedded into this group of three
different program areas is this idea
around continuous quality improvement
that we have
processes um that they're predictable
that we should have some standardized
work products and that we have the
capacity to work through what sometimes
seems like problems that are you know
unfixable intangible problems and yet it
was easy enough and I would I would also
put a highlight in here that one of the
ways that we could also do this is the
integration within the
department you all know and you tell us
every day how enormous the department is
and it's unwieldly and one of the things
that we had in this case was Chris and I
sitting together and being able to say
these are all our folks we can get them
in a room we can speak each other's
language and quite frankly translate
each other's language because each one
of them had their own responsibilities
you know DCF had their responsibility
for moving kids you have BFA who have
responsibilities of doing the paperwork
just right and um we were very pleased
with the ability to get this done build
out a place book for them and actually
set out work to do ahead of time so
that's our update today it's just a
little you know a little preview into
what goes on in Brown building and other
buildings around the state of the way in
which we try and work through these
problems so that our um public so that
the the youth that we are responsible
for and dcyf and others actually get the
care that they need so thank you we're
happy to take some questions thank you
for introducing the term I've been doing
these for years and I just didn't know
what it was called but a wise man also
known as the one who lives in my phone
said a Kaizen event is a short-term
focused Workshop that aims to improve
processes through rapid changes with the
goal of eliminating waste reducing costs
and enhancing quality that's it wow yeah
representative
Edwards thank you Mr chair I I I have to
point out that the father of the kaizon
was actually an American Demming who
went over in the Japanese stole all his
ideas and repackaged them so so put
America First that was that's a Deming
idea but uh the as I as I'm looking at
this I I want to just say I really
appreciate that you all are taking the
initiative to use uh good business
practices to keep looking for ways to do
better and um and I'm just wondering uh
now that you've done this uh this
mapping um the extent to which uh our it
systems are working in order to
implement this workflow or are you going
to have to do this workflow in sort of
an extraordinary way and work against
the it instead of having the it support
your workflow that's a a great question
I don't know if Chris you want to take
that and then I have one thing to add I
think we
haven't we haven't looked so much at the
it flow
however all staff Ed within DCF BFA and
Bureau of developmental Services they do
new use new heights for the eligibility
system um and so that I know is part of
their process and working I'm not 100%
sure um how much that really at this
point needs to be part of it I think
what is really important is they've
committed to monthly meetings to sit
down and talk about who's coming where
are we at with transitions but I can
double check on that yeah and I'll I'll
talk a little bit from DC DF so we have
an incredibly Antiquated um thing called
cwis which is the data system for DCF it
was built in the 9s we've been cobbling
it together and we've been working
probably for close to 5 years on
bringing on a new um system called
Granite families that's actually going
to be very close to getting to GNC very
soon it's been a tremendous process to
do the planning around a complex data
system and one of my hopes for that is
that it actually has the sort of
ticklers and reminders so that part of
the problem in this is that um kids at
certain age points you know like at 6
months who need to start doing this and
that and at this age you need to do this
that we want to have a Tickler that says
these are all the kiddos that are coming
up to age that's what I want our Heights
and um Granite families going to work
seamlessly
together
probably that could be in the future the
ebi I think they've been talking about
using that to actually help bring it
together because CCF needs to know okay
this person's 16 but so does BDS for
planning to make sure we know what the
child's needs are um to know what needs
to be done while they're under duif care
to prepare prepare them for Adult
Services so there needs to be that
better coordination yeah and the good
news is the number is fairly small so we
can have these monthly meetings and do
it in a little analog way but I think
there are huge opportunities to use our
systems better and and have systems that
actually can do that are current
Antiquated especially in DCF it just
simply can't do
it thank you I I've been encouraged to
keep my questions uh short and and so
that was a very long answer I think that
you you just said that no as of now the
it system has not been redesigned to
support the workflow okay so I I I I
just think we have so much tied up
potential in our it systems that I I
think for us to make the next couple of
steps uh we need to be thinking of
productivity we couldn't agree more yeah
thanks representative
Weber this is an easy one I understand
the lean concept I just don't remember
whether the acronym is L en or L Ean L
you Senator
Rosenwald thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for the work you've done on
this
um my question's more hypothetical I
think as you know there's going to be
discussion again this year about
breaking up the
department and I just wonder if
DCF and other services involving
children were split off from the rest of
Medicaid and the DD
Services whether this process would
still work as well as it seems like it's
going to that's a great question and so
um we think it wouldn't to to be to
answer short uh have a concise answer we
think it wouldn't it is much easier to
have these kind of conversations to
understand the data systems and the
workflows when we're all within the same
Department under the same leadership
priorities representative Woods thank
you Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question um um sounds like a good
program um but um is there a way to sort
of identify how well you've done I mean
it's nice to have another and secondly U
it um in some sense not trying to be a
detractor another layer of biography
have you created any new problems so a
how well have you done uh to have you
really solve the problem and and
secondly um are are there any new
problems you can Envision having been
created great you sure um I think
actually we will be able to identify it
through the actual transitions for the
Youth and so through these monthly
meetings and um probably anecdotally the
less emails that Trish and I have to be
involved in when the problem isn't
working right you know um but really
when youth transition and we know
exactly how it's going to be so the
team's going to be tracking that as well
and I actually think we're not creating
any new layers we're actually
streamlining and um aligning our
processes to reduce the
bureaucracy yes follow up thank you
thanks one of my concerns was my
daughter's a parent and deals with this
transition type of thing um I can
Envision the uh new transition team you
have in the middle actually creating a
longer time to get where you want to go
and that was That's the basis for my
question is that thank you I mean it is
our intent to make it as streamlined as
possible what we were finding was that
someone you know when this happens in
organizations we're not unique and you
know we're happy to show you our our
dirty laundry but like someone sends an
email it sit it has a question maybe
someone can't really answer and it sits
in someone's inbox for you know three
weeks this way there's actually a pro
everyone understands the process from
Soup To Nuts and again with these tick
through the U monthly meetings that were
acting quickly enough like soon enough
to in order to get that transition
happened on time so there isn't sort of
a fire drill going we have two weeks to
get this done for a kid and and I think
through the discovery process the team
spent a lot of time talking about the
roles and responsibilities so everybody
understanding you know what DCF has to
do what developmental Services has to do
what they can't do really helped I think
um to have a shared understanding
because at the end of the day and
Senator Rosen all this kind of goes to
your
question this child is the
responsibility of DHHS and it doesn't
matter if it's DCF developmental
Services they have to work together and
that representative
Weber um I have a question and a comment
if that's okay Mr chair it is um my
question following up on uh
representative Wood's question is my
understanding as I'm sort of scribbling
here is that you have not created a new
bureaucracy what you have done is have
two departments
interrelate to each other a little
better and that might in the long run
although it takes more time now will
both save time and we hope produce a
more secure route for the Youth who is
transitioning into adulthood is that
correct thank you for that excellent
summary okay thank you and then my
comment is because my other volunteer
job is as a casa um I just want to say
thank you very much for the added
attention that kids making this
transition without what we think of as
normal familial
supports um they have gotten
considerably more services and supports
over the last few years and thank you
for making that happen thank you this is
an incredibly vulnerable group of young
adults and it is our honor to serve them
and and as you note these are these are
youth that often have not had
connections to other um family members
and it's our responsibility to do this
right there have been a few people
recently who have suggested that dcyf
has broken out from DHHS and my argument
was put him under the same roof it's
much easier to talk and collaborate
would you agree I would agree with that
100% also a couple years ago or more I
was working a lot with the DD community
and I had a couple of observations one
was there needed to be greater
engagement with the actual uh loved ones
of hurting people I'm very happy to see
that that is improving that's the
feedback I'm getting and the other was
answers weren't easily coming to
questions and it sounds like this is
going to work to that problem too thank
thank you any other
questions thank
yeah chair next recognizes ctin Hansen
administrator division of Public Health
Services for healthcare acquired
update can you hear me now okay there we
go uh good afternoon chairman Pearson
and members of the committee I am here
today to provide an update on Healthcare
associate infections I'm going to
abbreviate that as Hai going forward
it's a mouthful um this is a
legislatively created program within the
division of Public Health Services I'm
also joined here today by Darlene Craig
manages the Hai program um in your
packets there are some blue folders um
similar to what Darlene has um you'll
see a letter to the committee um and an
executive summary for each 2023 data
report that I'll briefly discuss um
these will eventually be available
online within the next week or two um
and then I will also provide some budget
and other program
updates um since 2007 New Hampshire has
been heavily involved in reducing
Healthcare associate infections we have
provided these reports to the public
which is required under RSA 15132
through 35 and since the program was
established this requires certain Health
Care Facilities hospitals nursing homes
um dialysis centers and Ambulatory
Surgery centers to report certain
infections for context um I know I
presented to this group multiple years
in a row but I did want to provide this
additional detail to start but what are
Healthcare associate infections they are
infections that people acquire when
being treated for something else so for
example if a person has a knee
replacement and then later has an
infection in their wound or deep within
within their knee or a person has an
accident they're in the Intensive Care
Unit and then later have a bloodstream
infection due to improper infection
prevention practices these infections
are primarily preventable and patients
sometimes end up sicker after receiving
care for medical reasons the reports
that you have in front of you are
intended for the public so patients can
make decisions and discuss how to reduce
infections with their providers and we
also know how care facilities use this
information readily so they can work on
quality improvement initiatives to
reduce
infections so because these reports are
very lengthy I am going to just provide
some very um high level updates and
highlights for each report for hospitals
Ambulatory Surgery centers arc's
dialysis centers and long-term care
facilities all hospitals reported as
required in
2023 um sure because I'm trying to
figure out what I need to write down and
what I don't yep it could you point me
to the piece of paper in our folder that
you're working off of if there is one
because if there is then I don't have to
yes and and I will actually save you
from writing everything down I can
provide my these are talking points and
I'd be happy to share those forence lat
to save your hand yes um the letter in
front of you also does address some of
these highle points that I've got I
don't want you to have to thumb through
150 pages though I'll save you from that
as
well um these infections are central
line bloodstream infections catheter
Associated urin tract infections and
surgical site infections following
certain procedure types they also report
Chester defal or SEI infection and
aggregate Healthcare Personnel
vaccination rates overall in the
Hampshire in 2023 hospitals observe
fewer infections and predicted based on
National Data and this is statistically
significant um there were significantly
few infections ac across all of these
main categories and only 135 were
reported for the state um and also 24
hospitals reported 174 SE diff
infections as well and this is
significantly lower than the national
rate as well Healthcare Personnel
influenza vaccination rate was 89.9%
this is a slight decrease decrease from
the prior year of 90.4% however
hospitals have routinely and
continuously had higher vaccination
rates than other facility types
Ambulatory Surgery centers um there
eight reported surgical site infections
um there were a total of six infections
that were reported um this is lower than
is reported or is predicted based on
National Data though a slight increase
from the prior year which was Zero um
Healthcare Personnel influenza
vaccination rate was 80.1% which is a
decrease from the prior year um which
was
87.7% and since we started collecting
these data certain antibiotic um
intravenous therapy or Pro prophylaxis
has been remained above
96% um since we started working on this
in 15 of those facilities though they
did not report they either had
challenges with incomplete data or did
not have qualifying procedures in which
to report since they have to have
specific procedures to report that
measure but they've routinely had very
high adherence uh to protecting patients
for that measure dialysis centers 18
reported four types of vascular access
site infections in addition they also
reported vaccination rate among their
Healthcare Personnel overall the number
of infections was also lower in dialysis
compared to national data to 299
infections were reported as compared to
379 for the prior year of those four
types that are reported however uh local
access site infections that was actually
significantly higher than National Data
so something that we'll be monitoring
and looking into Healthcare Personnel
influence of vaccination Dialysis in
dialysis centers was
52.6% which is a slight decrease from
the prior year
55.0% in long-term care facilities which
this includes a broad cat or of skilled
nursing assisted living and Residential
Care Facilities they only report
influenza vaccination rates and in those
facilities that um percentage was
50.1% which is an increase from the
prior season which is
37.8% and the vaccination coverage in
those facilities range from 0 to
100% some other program activities um
our program conducted over 100
investigations in 2022 or 2023 which is
more than double compared to the prior
year this includes outbreaks infection
control breach events drug diversion of
injectable medications and antimicrob
resistant and unusual organisms our
program also continues its efforts to
coordinate antimicrobial resistant
pathogens response uh for example um in
2023 we had 84 antibiotic resistant
organisms reported to us under RSA
141c some of these required patient
notification and screening this
primarily includes bacteria that have
enzymes that can spread resistance to
other bacteria in that setting uh the
program continues to see a trend of more
of these drug resistant bacteria
requiring substantial effort to prevent
further
transmission and then lastly our program
conducted 20 infection prevention
assessments within Healthcare
settings so per RSA 140
15134 um the department is also required
to report on Hai program costs and
facility fees um to the healthcare H or
HHS oversight the House and Senate
weighs and me
um and this also includes the fa fees
paid for um by Healthcare facilities in
2023 State fiscal year the AI program
budget to complete these reports was
348,000 and then State fiscal year we
are also awarded $328 $817 through one
particular grant called the epidemiology
laboratory capacity grant that Grant was
later reduced by 40% in the following
fiscal year however our program has
received several other fundings funding
sources to cover operational costs of
our Hai program was which also includes
Hai reporting so due to receipt of our
federal funds we have not had to fee
facilities and assess fees in 2023 nor
have we had to fee facilities for the
past four or so years and previous years
when we have had to fee um those fees
range from 22,000 to 150,000 depending
on the size the facility and the number
of procedures they
perform so in closing in this coming
year we really are looking to create a
lot of efficiencies in our program by
making these data much more accessible
and interactive to the public so we
don't have such static large heavy dense
reports we'd like to make them more
accessible online for for everyone to
access we also continue to prioritize
our our outbreak response responding to
antimicrobial resistant infections and
Drug diversion events and infection
control breach events as they occur and
we are also expanding infection
prevention training to various
Geographic areas of the state as well as
impr proving the number of organizations
that go to those trainings including
Emergency Medical Services dialysis and
correctional facilities and this
training will also respond to gaps in
drug diversion reporting as well as
enhancements to infection prevention and
that's all I have for you today pending
any questions thank you for bearing with
me through all that it's exciting that
the numbers of bad things in many
categories is going down is this just
something that happens periodically or
were there intentional actions that
perhaps in part cause this it's an
excellent question you know I I've been
presenting for over 14 years and I am
seeing our infection ratios decrease
over time and continuously being
remaining below the national average
which is excellent I do think though
this work takes a village it's not just
our program we are a piece of the puzzle
there are many individuals involved with
reducing infections across the state
from infection prevention at at
hospitals to Direct Care Providers to
our program bringing training and
responding if we see increases so I
think we play a role but I don't think
we are the primary players to reducing
these infections I will say uh for the
reducing uh the spread in transmission
of these antibiotic resistant
organisms our program is heavily
involved in reducing transmission and
spread and I do think we have a direct
impact in reducing spread we have a
pretty low burden compared to many other
states um across the country and
regionally um we we don't really see as
many of these organisms as other states
could you very briefly give just a few
examples of what people are doing which
may seem to have a cause and
effect sure so um for antibiotic
resistant bacteria if we identify a
individual that has one of these these
bacteria we will work with a provider
and a healthcare facility to identify
patients that may have been near that
patient so if there's a roommate or
patient subsequent that may have had
care after them and we kind of have this
approach where we look at the potential
risk and we'll work with that facility
to contact patients and let them know of
that potential risk and exposure and
then they will have testing and
screening and we work closely with a
laboratory in New York state to do that
screening and so we have um our staff
maybe a handful three or so staff will
work to either work with the facility or
we'll directly make patient calls and
notifications so they can have screening
done did I answer your question okay yes
thank you any other questions repres
Senator Rosenwald thank you Mr chairman
I have two questions one
um I'm just curious
why we're getting 2023 data when we're
six months
into the next fiscal year already that's
a really good question and I did
anticipate it so we have these data
produced every year they end of the
calendar year so right now calendar year
so it's calendar year data and it takes
around six months of reconciliation so
between the end of the year and to when
we close that out a month later so
around February March we start a
Reconciliation process we go back and
forth with facilities to make sure what
they reported was accurate so we we have
a very Rob bu quality assurance piece
and then we do a lot of data cleaning
and it takes a massive effort to put
these reports together we are also
slightly delayed this year because we
also had transition and Staffing the
role primarily responsible for this for
this work was vacated uh due to tr staff
transition in September so we are
running around six months delay due to
some of those challenges and also we've
had nearly double the number of
Investigations and when we are
prioritizing our work we have to make
sure we put Patients First and respond
to those events immediately and then
we'll come back to these reports and if
fact follow up yes thank you thank you
um so I'm struck by the difference in
the flu vaccine rate between Hospital
staff and dialysis center and long-term
care facility staff and um I'm wondering
what if anything the department can do
clinics
or I I don't even know what to bring
that flu
vaccine rate up at dialysis centers and
nursing
homes we we collect the different or the
data across all facility types we are
not requiring any types of vaccine and
we are also working with our facilities
to ensure there are requirements they
have to make sure it's available um what
we do is we we collect the aggregate
data and we put it in the reports and we
let those reports really Drive some of
that change and it has we have seen some
of that change some facilities have
implemented a variety of policies which
they are actually in the reports
themselves we do have some documentation
on that um and hospitals have um
continuously been around 90% and they've
really kind of LED that charge other
facility types I am seeing a change um
there has been site decrease from the
prior year that could be just normal
variation of decrease and changes over
time and I think there's we need more
time to really know that and I don't
have my crystal ball to say if we're
going to see increases but I I do think
facilities are making conservative
efforts to make sure vaccine is
available to their health care Personnel
um this has been an ongoing challenge we
also have had some challenges with um
reporting as well though um sometimes
facilities don't know they have to
report and so we do have some facilities
that haven't reported in some of these
reports and so we have we are making a
concerted effort ourselves as a program
to reach out to all of those facility
types to make sure they know to report
so some of the data could be skewed if
facilities that may have high
vaccination rates actually didn't didn't
report um so we don't have a full
comprehensive look for all of them uh we
will work closely with our colleagues in
other areas and we do provide this data
to our immunization colleagues to be
able to provide education and resources
for healthcare workers so they can make
informed decisions for themselves just a
commment I mean you can't go go to a
grocery store or Pharmacy without seeing
a sign in the window saying fre blue
shot is your vaccine yeah so it's so
easy
convenient and
inexpensive I just
wonder why the raids are so it's good
and this is also self-reporting too so
you know we could be missing some Nuance
there with if people didn't run a report
or self-report for themselves thank you
Senator gray um I'm I want to give Mr
Williams a go do um the chair's question
about whether the Improvement was
statistically um important or not uh I
think that there are people in the
department who might be able to answer
that question and figure out what the
control limits on this process is and
actually tell us that so if you would at
least come back and tell me whether you
have or don't have the people that that
could do that analysis I would certainly
appreci appreciate that we do we're well
staffed with some very strong
epidemiologists and several people
behind you are pointing to you
volunteering you to do this again you
you know it's it's the statistician and
those that can develop the control
limits on the process that allows you to
answer the question that the chair asks
so and I think that's something I would
like to look more into we have explored
looking at vaccination and outbreaks
we've also looked at um
how like how can we really pull
ourselves out and see are we making a
change among this puzzle of many other
partners also working to reduce knee
infections for example that is something
we'd like to do more of I think the
challenge is our Staffing Resources
having to often be redirected to
outbreak response and when we are
redirected it really is challenging to
pull ourselves out of a very in-depth
analysis project but Senator GR
appreciate your feedback and we will
look into that and we'll bring it back
to the best of our ability for for the
liberal arts guide a piggyback on the
engineer if you can identify a few
things that seem really to have made a
difference the medical facility of which
I'm part-time CEO would like to
implement those things so this is a this
is um spiraling for the
good other
questions uh representative uh
Edwards I I'm going to um look at the
data here and and tell you I'm a little
bit confused by something and maybe
maybe you can clarify it for me uh uh we
predicted uh increased or we predicted
more infections that than we actually
observed um in a year in which the
vaccination rate went down for the flu
and and we have some of the these
hospitals like Memorial at
88.3% uh several of them below or in the
70s and below and I'm just wondering if
uh there's an in if we've got the right
correlation
between wanting to have the vaccine and
expecting it to make a difference in the
infection rate because this little bit
of data makes me question whether or not
there's an authentic correl
between a high vaccination rate in the
hospital and whether or not it's
positively influencing observed
infections do do you do you correlate
this like Memorial Hospital do we know
how many observed infections occurred
per that
hospital that is an amazing question and
I I really appreciate you for bringing
it up so the influence of vaccination
rates and that tracking is really it's a
best practice measure just like
antimicrobial prophylaxis Administration
they are good practices to ensure
patient safety but they aren't cause and
effect to these infections that you're
looking at in the report I think where
you may we would want to do a little
more research into it and and digging is
looking at outbreaks that may have
occurred in that facility uh of
influenza For That season that we
actually have that vaccination rate for
this law does not tie those together but
it is something we have explored and we
want to look into um so there isn't a
direct cause and effect but there's also
very specific ways to calculate this
this the numbers that you see in front
of you yeah um the facilities have to
report with these very stringent
standards of what meets a criteria of an
infection and these infections are like
bacterial infections after a knee
surgery which are not the same as um
influenza but there are certain Pro so
it's a mix of process measures and
infection me measures and they not they
don't all go hand inand together right
so so if I may just to follow up uh so
um the implication of having the data in
the same report is that it's one of the
things uh that is a positive influence
on managing the infection and there
doesn't seem to be just from this high
level correlation of the data to suggest
that and this goes back to Senator Rosen
wald's question how do we get the
influenza vaccination rate up higher I'm
I'm not sure that that's important from
this
report and I will I will note we are
looking at all these measures these are
all very much specific in our rules and
our statute and we may not need to
collect all these measures um the
surgical Care Improvement ones from the
Ambulatory Surgery centers they've
consistently been higher high high
percentage and we've seen that since
2012 is that worth the return on
investment I don't know I think we'd
like to revise and look at some of them
all right thank you
m representative Woods oh thank you Mr
chair um I'm GNA ask a couple questions
just for clarification I have not a
chance to really look at and digest so
it's a lot of information and I'm new to
the committee as well um the first
question was um when you uh identify U
infections for ambulatory centers are
these truly freestanding or or uh like
conquered Orthopedics used to have one
in-house uh Bedford uh but now hospitals
have ambulatory surgeries with within
the hospital now are the ones in the
hospital a
hospital or are they an ambulatory
surgicals I think go ahead for that
question that's a really good question
so they are based on lure status so it's
Ambulatory Surgery C is licensed under
the RS say 151 so majority of them I
think are freestanding I think there may
have been one that was embedded or close
to a
facility so the ones that follow yes um
so the ones that are in truly in
hospital that are ambulatory providing
the same services that a freestanding
with they're categorized with a
hospital they they are not probably
included in these reports if they are
under the hospital lure because those
measures in the Ambulatory Surgery
component are different for the
freestanding ones than the hospital
measures so there's different um so for
hospitals for example there's surgery
site infections following knee abdominal
hysterectomy colon and um coronary
artery bypass procedures and Ambulatory
Surgery centers those are really very um
invasive procedures with the
freestanding clinics we worked with
ambul surger Ambulatory Surgery centers
and so they report certain breast hernia
and open reduction of fracture
procedures so it really does depend on
the lure um so if they are a facility
and they do ambulatory outpatient Same
Day Care procedures but if it's under a
hospital license they would not be
included in this report yeah I was my
concern because as we transition to more
ambulatory
surgeries the risks that are involved
with an ambulatory patient versus an
in-house patient is is different as good
to have that kind of that other followup
if I could yes
um um if if someone has u in a a total
hip arthroplasty and they have a
infection six months later and they're
admitted they have an infection how is
that
categorized so it's excellent question I
I wish I brought all the definitions in
front of me for you um so we don't we
don't track hip procedures though that
has been discussed if that's something
that should considered but basically it
depends if if they have any um record or
documentation that there was maybe an
infection immediately after their
procedure so even if it was superficial
on their skin and then 6 months later it
became a really deep infection that may
be included but there's various criteria
of time cut off so it may be within 30
days they're no longer counted as an
infection but you need to have some sort
of medical documentation that indicates
that there was an infection Brewing
before they can really count it in
infection um and there's a lot of um
kind of stop Gap measures within the
system that collects this information
that guys reporters to make sure that
they follow the criteria to a tea well
well thank you I just would would like
to offer another comment I I think it's
really important because as as I was
alluding there's a lot more surgeries
being done and to
differentiate uh to and so for the
practicing physician to be able to know
is this number really applicable to my
patient surgery or inpatient U because
right now we're start we're doing U
total hips now
outpatient um when I was in training for
to to have thought back when I was in
training this would be done as an
outpatient uh but this is going to be
crucially important uh in this process I
appreciate that thank you
representative
Weber thank you and this is again
because I've been scribbling enough not
looking through your report which is
what I would do if I wasn't no no no no
it's not that it's it's a question that
I just don't want to seem to be being
inattentive but um I'm following up on
representative
Edward's questions about flu
vaccines um does the report because all
that I'm hearing you talk about are
infections of the sort that I think of
as being bacterial or or surgical
related
does the report also talk about
influenza
outbreaks it does not it's not required
under this particular law so we only
report on what's under the RSA 15132
through 34 so follow up so there is
nothing that would would uh provide
information on that correlation that in
your report because that's not what this
is intended to do correct it's not in
this
report anyone else yes senator wal also
following up on representative Edward's
question we know that about
10% of the residents at the Veterans
Home die from influenza every year um do
we know what that death rate is in the
rest of long-term care
facilities that's a good question so
I'll I'll put on my my other um hat out
of my other work which is kind of our
surveillance of other infectious
diseases influenza alone is not a
reportable condition in public health so
we do not track influenza cases across
across the state so it is really hard
for us to know when we get reports of
outbreaks is this on par with the rest
of the data across the state that said
it is required to report certain
outbreaks or clusters of infectious
disease including influenza so if we do
track outbreaks and clusters if there
was um if there was interest we could
always pull a data request on that but
we we may not necessarily have total
count in those clusters or outbreaks of
all those ill and then those who aren't
ill to be able to get um a a rate of
infection we should be able to provide a
mortality rate of those outbreaks or of
the season um but Where It's Tricky is
not everyone will have testing and not
everyone may show signs and symptoms but
we can do our best to try to pull that
by season
though seeing No Hands thank you for
your report thank you so much for all
your qu great qu and and very
inquisitive questions thank you and just
remember they volunteered you for
something uh
oh Mr chair yes um I'd like to offer a
comment just an observation that we've
used the term correlation fairly
liberally well um and that's okay but
but I think um for myself uh and I would
encourage all of us that there there's
an old saying in physics that says uh
correlation does not mean mean CA and I
think we sometimes if we look at data
and I don't I'm not trying to implied
data is not applicable I don't mean that
but we just something I think we as a
committee just have to be very very
mindful of correlations do not mean
causation that's a Maxim in the world I
live into thank you uh uh let's see okay
State Health assessment and State Health
ship I won't use my shash ship
Redemption joke because I used it last
year you know what you can um
oh we it leads to a lot of good joke
sir um so
hello my name is Whitney Hammond I'm the
interm deputy director for the division
of Public Health
Services um and I asked our current
chair um so the new chair of the Sha
ship Council to join me today so I think
you know most people I'm Dave Nagel I'm
representative
physician okay um and I just wanted to
make sure people are aware so the Sha
ship Council annual report was sent
electronically earlier this week to you
all and I don't have any additional
materials that I brought in hard copy My
Hope was to be able to just engage and
answer questions so to not we don't have
a ton of dense information to go over um
so to start I figured I would uh just
give a little bit of the context because
some of you are very much familiar with
the SHA ship Council and for some it may
be new
information um so the council was
established through statute um HB
1639 and was introduced in January of
2020 it was signed into law July 29th
2020 uh and established this Council and
then in the next legislative session in
2021 there was HB 157
introduced um as I understand it the
initial intent behind that legislation
was to eliminate the council because of
concerns about duplication between the
uh community Health assessments and
Community Health Improvement plans that
hospitals develop uh but through some
back and forth and and hearings the
decision was made to move forward
because it was determined to be not
duplicative and the new legislation
expanded the members that are on the
council So for anybody who's familiar
with that um it's a very large Council
of 40 different appointed members um the
interesting thing about that is with 40
appointed members there's a very broad
range of perspectives represented on
that Council so everything from um
critical access hospitals public health
networks federally qualified Health
Centers uh we have people from housing
Transportation EMS um so it's a a large
Council but has um so many different
perspectives at the
table um so the scope of what was in the
legislation for that Council to achieve
was uh the completion of a state health
assessment um and the goal behind that
was to understand health status in New
Hampshire there was a there was language
saying that we should engage with
community members and gather input at a
local level to help understand um what's
going on in New Hampshire and that that
information gathering would then be used
to identify gaps in access to care and
services uh there was also emphasis on
us mapping healthc care services and
then describing the role of all the
different state agencies in terms of um
impacting Health in New Hampshire so we
did that um the so we call it the shaw
the shaw was developed and completed in
2020 and it is available online there's
a a web-based version of it with live
data dashboards the second charge of the
council was to then take that data and
develop what we call the the State
Health Improvement plan or ship um that
was completed in
2023 um the legislation said the ship
needed to address how to improve health
and wellness how to improve specific
Health outcomes and how to optimize
Public Health and Human Service
delivery um the so in the ship there
were four broad domains identified by
the council that needed to be addressed
those were access to opportunity um
which is really looking at things like
do people have basic needs met do they
have adequate food do they have adequate
Broadband access uh do they have
transportation housing then there was a
domain around community that included
things like environmental health threats
um whether people are safe in their
homes as a form of community then there
was a domain around social connectedness
which was talked about things like
engaging in um voting and just Civic
engagement and then the kind of typical
health status and outcomes was the
fourth domain um so the ship was
finalized in 2023 with those domains and
the thought of the council at that time
was that each of the council members
would become a champion for the ship and
would bring the ship to their own
organization or their own work in New
Hampshire um and figure out how to align
underneath the ship so I was going to
talk a little bit today about how the
department has done that um so as a
result of having the finalized ship the
department has then identified
priorities underneath it and has
developed their own internal um plan for
how to change specific measures related
to those
priorities um just to give a little more
detail on that uh so we have five
priority areas that we're focusing in on
heart disease
um we are focusing on maternal and child
health child mental health sexually
transmitted infections and environmental
health um and then you can and those
priorities came from you know what where
there were opportunities and where there
was work being done internal to the
department yeah which ones
the sure um heart
disease uh Maternal Child
Health childhood Mental Health
infections and
then environmental
health
sure um and so it was it was sort of
fascinating because the council did
their developed the plan and then for
the next year they did the review of The
Shaw and the ship which is the third
charge from the legislation that they're
going to annually look at is this still
relevant is this still what we need to
be focused on so for the last year and I
think that was at some point when
representative Nagel joined us we were
doing the work of going through and
talking about what is the current status
in all these different areas that the
ship touches and interestingly enough a
lot of those presentations focused in on
those five priority areas that we are
now focused on for the Department um and
then I'm guessing many of you have heard
about the Department's road map and so
we have worked to connect our internal
ship to the road map so we have two
priorities from the list that I just
said that are clearly articulated in our
road map so we call it healthy babies
healthy moms which is the Maternal Child
Health and then environmental health is
also in the Department's road map um and
some of the things that are being
impacted uh in in our work in that area
are improving lead screening um giving
Healthcare Providers more guidance
around pasas and how to work with their
patients who have concerns about that
and then getting more moms into prenatal
and postnatal
care do you have anything you'd like to
add about what we've been working
on um a little bit um this is exciting
opportunity for me um I think we're in a
little bit of a transition right now
which is neat because it gives us an
opportunity to relook at where we are
where we want to go um
I learned my lesson about opening my
mouth I I did ask a question at an hhsa
meeting once where I asked them very
specifically this looks great but where
are we headed the next thing I know I
got a call and I'm the vi the chair so
um you know this is an exciting
opportunity for me um to unite Health
Providers and and organizations to
basically a mutual goal of Public Health
and something I've been interested in
for a long time time because as you know
there's a lot of fragmentation in our
Health Care system and and if this is a
way to break down barriers that's really
important to
me how's that it's great so I that's
what I had as an update but I'm happy to
have seeing none thank you thank
you did you have written materials and
have I lost them in my mauve paper here
the only written I so I didn't bring
anything in hard copy we have the
electronic annual report that that's
fine I just wanted to be sure I had
linked the people and the reports to the
extent that I could do that and can you
tell me your name again please because
there were two names and I didn't write
it down because I assumed the name would
be here but I don't know which one you
are so I'm Whitney Hammond okay that I
that I got the right guess thank you
good thank if if I could make one more
comment one of my priority goals is to
change the acronym for the organization
to avoid future jokes at the beginning
of meetings as you would that was an
observation yes thank you it has been
said at every meeting well don't give up
the
ship the Sha Mr chair yes sir I could I
ask them okay we got we got the question
starting yes representative Woods no no
thank you um um you mentioned You' send
it electronically I there was a an issue
with my emails and I'm getting it sorted
out and I somehow I got downloaded with
150 emails last night and I I don't know
whether I really would like to look at
this uh what's the correct term this
particular report I want to use that
word sure the annual report sh y well I
didn't want to use that okay but and as
a consequence I'm not sure that I really
did get it but I really would like to
see it is there should I resend know
yeah it's things it's been squared away
so you can just look up my legislative
thing and send it perfect I'll do that
thank you there was a change over in
emails this past week and uh things went
crazy yeah I know that
feeling's a
request yes challenges representative
McDonald my my thing well maybe not um I
I do have the I did get the report I'm
looking at it right now and it's very
comprehensive and very impressive
and um since we're talking about names
you've spelled Dr Nagel's name wrong oh
isn't it nag e l thank you sir it's on n
a l e on the list well for fun my phone
auto corrects him to Bagel so at least
she wasn't Bagel it's not as bad as that
but that was the business I was going to
create because it just sells
Bagels thank you anyone else thank you
last
you next up tuition waiver for children
in State foster care or
KN it's a pleasure to be here again with
you folks and I want to thank you all
for your service on this
committee I am representing Rob rodler
my name is Elizabeth NE and my position
is with the Adolescent program at
dcyf as youth engagement specialist and
it's broad but part of it encompasses
the tuition waiver program and my name
Coello so um I'm not going to read the
whole report to you I am going to to
highlight some things that I think are
important as we look at the program and
its
success we continue to see a significant
positive change to the tuition waiver
program through the passage of house
bill to FN a local when our youth-driven
work with the state legislature created
a welcomed expansion of the program
these changes included increasing the
number of wavers per system community
college and university from 15 to
35 moving the age limitation for
application from 23 to 26 because we
know all youth do not follow traditional
patterns of higher
ed uh we allowed youth who left DCF care
for Guardianship and remain in
guardianship until the the age of 18 or
who were placed with a relative out of
state to be eligible for the
waiver this year there was an
unprecedented 84 certified applicants
for the tuition waiver program by
comparison there were 68 in
24 49 in
23 and 48 in
22 35 waiver slots so all the waivers we
had for the University system were
taken um 13 of them went to returning
students which is really
great and uh I lost my place here uh 30
uh waivers were um applied for in the
community college system 14 of them were
return return learning
students we're still because the
community college system is much more
fluid we're still processing wavers for
youth that want to start in January this
this month um so it's kind of like a
ongoing
process the university system is is much
more streamlined it goes from September
to
May so um so yeah it's it's been a very
successful increase and I hope that this
year it will be the same sort of trend
upward um I invited Fred here
today because he would like to share how
the program has impacted he and his
life good afternoon chairman Pearson and
the rest of the members of the committee
my name is Fred
Coello and my wife and I are the
grandparents and guardians of my
grandson
James I would like to take a moment to
thank the
legislature bethney and the entire team
for making tuition affordable for my
grandson James is a remarkable young man
he is like all the other kids in our
community except he was raised by his
grandparents he was a Cub Scout and a
Boy
Scout he was an honor roll student in
middle school and in high
school and he graduated with honors from
high
school James is currently in his last
semester at
nhti and plans to continue
studying
architecture at Keen state next fall my
wife and I are extremely proud of his
accomplishments we are retired now and
it would be extremely difficult for us
to make this happen if it wasn't for
this
support James couldn't be here today
because he's attending
class however he would like me to say
that he's very thankful for the
program reducing his financial burden
and supporting his effort to attend
college will help him normalize his life
while contributing to his future
success thank
you also in your
packet you might some of you might
remember I brought this young person
with me last year yeah and she we texted
last night and she gave me permission to
share her thank you note that she sent
me and um to tell you all that she is
she made High honors this past
semester so she is on our way to a very
successful
Edwards so it sounds like uh we're doing
some good for some kids uh you know
there a lot of people that are still
paying their their tuition to go yes um
and it sounds like there's some
gratitude on the basis of the re
absolutely uh I'm I'm just curious if
there's any in if there's a way for them
to explicitly give back to the program
somehow is there a way for them to after
they've gone on they become successful
they're making money is there any way
for them to donate back to this very
specific program to help the next wave
of kids that's an excellent idea and
absolutely we'll take that under
consideration at this point I don't
believe that that exists so you know um
our youth give back in other ways by
Yeah by um we have a but everyone could
give back if everyone got free tuition
right so all right thank you thank you
representative
Edwards anyone
else these are wonderful stories you're
telling thank
you sometimes we wonder is our money
doing any good it's good to know that
sometimes it is yes I would agree with
that thank you thank you for coming I
think Senator gray might have had
Senator Rosen wal
oh I'm sorry representative
McDonald well I get for sitting in the
wrong place sorry um yeah looking at the
um on page two of of the report U with a
letter that was addressed to Senator
bdel and representative Pearson um so
the program was started in 2013 is that
correct that sounds correct yes and is
is the uh the numbers under the
university system of New Hampshire and
the
if I may have a followup Mr chairman I'm
sorry yes sir and the community college
system are those the total to date or is
just the total for the current I think
it's it's broken down in the pages at
the end oh okay and I believe this
starts at 2008 obviously I wasn't around
then because I was a career educator so
um I only joined the Department three
three and a half years ago
so thank you thank you
coming next up New Hampshire Health
Officers Association annual
report Wayne Whitford president Sophia
good afternoon chairman peon and the
committee uh my name is Wayne Whitford
I'm president of New Hampshire Health
Officers Association I'm here at the
invitation of the committee to discuss
the state read this report uh we have
sent it to the committee members and I
have additional copies if anybody needs
a copy we can provide it to
you
uh the report shows each Town's Health
officer the ability to respond to Public
Health handsets that face them in the
community report current report covers a
period of November 1st to October 30th
of 2024 that November 1st 2023 to
October 30th
2024 State uh Rance report Health
offices required under RSA 128 col 11 be
subed annually to the committee as of
November 1st of each
year I a report in in 2024 there were
325 uh Health officers in the state
that's up from 305 to to
uh in 23 we could we interrupt for just
a minute here please I'm sorry do we
have copy printed copies of this
or it's it's okay if we don't I just we
do have copies right here okay
yeah are there enough for the committee
uh I have three copies right here oh
okay we can send additional cop it's
quite all right if I could have one copy
for the for the minutes and and I just
wanted to be sure I hadn't lost
something so thank you I believe it was
in the uh pre-meeting uh stuff that was
sent to us okay because my Aid did print
mine so well my Aid it is yeah I haven't
had an aid in nine years thank you we
weage
actually appointed till yesterday so
some of us are a little behind in terms
senator okay thank you as I was saying
the
3255 Health officers in the state 199 of
those Health officers are a member of
our association
uh one of our focuses for this year is
Health offic
collaboration uh in addition to being
the secretary to the local Board of
Health uh we also uh meet and work with
other members of the community such as
uh firefight Fire Chiefs uh Town
administrators code enforcement and so
forth State and regionally we do work
with the public health networks Dees
DHHS food protection adult and child
services and a number of other
agencies uh this support report uh shows
the Readiness to respond to health uh
threats such as involvement with the
health
network uh we are heavily involved in
training three-hour training initials uh
Health officer trainings on roles and
responsibilities continuing education
and health officer additional uh two a
year training sessions as well as
webinars uh do you want to speak a
little bit about training
sessions sure um hello chair and members
of the committee my name is Sophia
Johnson and I lead the health officer
liaison program at the department to
just step back a little bit this is a
really unique report in the fact that um
the legislature in 2021 wanted to get a
better idea of how ready our Municipal
Health officers were to respond to local
threats in their community ities um so
this requirement brought together the
health officer Association and the
department who who both work with this
group of officials to figure out what is
that Readiness so this report is really
a joint effort between the health
officer Association and the department
to gauge the Readiness um at a a on a
yearly interval um so as Wayne was
saying uh the department does have um
very strong training initiatives this
local Workforce um as the report
describes is primarily volunteer and if
they're not volunteers they're often
serving in multiple Municipal roles in
their community so it's a very important
position in terms of being able to
respond to public health issues but
they're often stretched to work in other
Municipal roles we find that they're
often also the fire chief or also the
building code inspector and they come
into this role with not necessarily a
wide range of of understanding of
environmental health and public threats
um so our our role is to really bring
those Health officers up to speed and
provide the training that they need to
be effective in their roles um so this
year in particular what our program is
really focusing on is making um
connections to other state programs to
provide more sufficient and more
comprehensive training um as you may be
aware Health officers can respond to
things like septic failures and they can
also respond to hoarding conditions so
as a result they work with a lot of
different state agents ranging from the
Department of Ed um to subsurface over
at Dees um so we are working
collaboratively with all those State
programs to figure out how can we build
a really comprehensive training schedule
um training plan and that's something I
think that this report really highlights
this year is the success of building
those
collaborations um the other thing I do
want to touch on in this report is um we
generated the content of this report
from suring local Health officers so
this is not not just the health officer
Association and the department sitting
around a table writing this report this
is generated from the communities and
from the local Health officers and what
they're telling us um are those main
threats that you can see at the end of
of the report they don't have the
capacity necessarily to respond to what
they need to in their communities um
because of the fact that they are
volunteer or they are serving in
multiple um
roles um they respond to a lot of
different issues like septic failures
that they say are just occurring very
frequently to what they've seen in the
past and they need more support so
that's why we're building relationships
with Dees to provide that additional
support um if you have any other
questions yeah I'm I'm happy to take
them at this time Wayne did you have
anything else to add no I just want to
uh uh comment that the public health
threats which are identified in the
report include housing issues such as
safe and sanitary housing rental house
conditions inadequate zoning
septic system compliance like Sophia
mentioned addressing the fail SE septic
systems and coordinating with Dees
subservice Bureau nuisances such as
odors noises septic trash junk yards and
so forth and lack of capacity as Sophia
mentioned many of the health officers
are wearing several different hats or
serve on a volunteer
basis uh this is a shared position uh 86
full-time Health offices are most in the
cities of the State uh 57 P time and
there's 72 volunteer Health offices and
that has to do with inadequate budgets
and there is no state or federal uh
support for the health offices I have a
question uh I represent several towns so
I do not know who the local Health
officer is in each one how do I find out
that's a great question um so every town
in New Hampshire under RSA 128 is
required to have a health office officer
um and our department is responsible for
receiving nominations from towns and
conducting those appointments so because
of that process we do publish monthly a
report on our website that highlights um
the health officers for each town and
their contact information so I am happy
to share that link with you thank you
you're welcome other questions
representative
Weber so w would things like um
infestation of bed bugs and Rental
housing fall within your purview yes
okay thank you that's a great question
yes Senator gray I now have an answer
for a
constituent page three section one where
you list I can't tell whether the 19
vacancies are Health officers Deputy
Health officers Etc so I don't know if
there's 19 communities you know from
this report from from the other report
that you said is available yes I
probably could glean that information
but if it's there a difference between
if it's 19 communities don't have health
officers at all or 19 communities don't
have Deputy Health officers but normally
have them that makes a big difference
and the report I don't think really
tells me that that's a great question
and we will make that note for next year
and we will add that um clarification
that number is the um the communities
that don't have a health officer so that
they are towns are required to have a
health officer they're not necessarily
required to have a deputy Health officer
so if there are 19 communities that
don't have um a health officer it is
that Primary Health officer and in those
situations um our office is aware of
those um vacancies and our staff reach
out to the towns and have conversations
with them on progress to to nominating
another Health officer um in situations
where if an emergency were to arise in
those towns um adjacent Health officers
so in surrounding communities are giving
and the ability to go into those towns
and respond so there's still that um
option yes follow up um and that's
another part in the uh changes that we
did to the health officer statute last
year uh one of the things was that there
was people there were people who were in
joining communities that you shared a
health officer how is that handled in
the report is that still the community
that's sharing
still listed as one of the 19 or I again
just great question so if communities
are sharing a health officer under RSA
128 they can only do so for a period of
30 days so that information not is not
necessarily reflected in this report
because it is for a temporary basis some
health officers um are appointed in both
towns so the health officer in
Chichester and Pittsfield may be the
same person but they go through separate
appointment processes so they're both
towns follow up so just clarifying it my
mind so a person who is temporary can
only be there 30 days but they could be
appointed as a part-time in two
different locations and serve the full
terms that is
correct
thank representative
Weber brings up a question for me when
we say
fulltime I'm assuming that depending on
the size of the
municipality I come from a town of just
north of
4,000 uh we're not talking about
full-time anything because in my town
it's the
vet um and he's pretty busy um it it's
it's not a full necessarily a full-time
position though it could be in in larger
municipalities
that is correct the statute doesn't say
that towns have to have a full-time
Health officer it says they have to have
a health officer so towns are very
creative and how they meet that
requirement representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman uh
looking at the report on page two I
believe it is uh it talks about all of
the people that uh local Health offices
collaborate with and um it's quite a
list very impressive and thorough list
talks about Department of Public Health
Services I believe it is infectious
disease staff and it talks about rabies
and mosquito born ill disease I assume
that's not limited to that or there's a
lot of other infectious diseases other
than those so there are other infectious
infectious diseases um and normally the
health officers are not pulled into
those types of um outbreaks however if a
health officer is asked to for some
reason participate in another type of
outbreak or another infectious disease
they do have to go through a
confidentiality training um and sign a
form that's saying that they've had all
the hippo necessary training so um
because of the sensitive health
information that's associated with some
of those conditions there are other
requirements that Health officers have
to meet in order to participate in those
types of situations did I have a
followup followup um I'm just curious
how those two particular diseases or
conditions were arrived at uh just
research or frequency or severity or so
with rabies um and arboviral diseases so
mosquitoes and ticks um if the state
identifies an area that is seeing um
above average normal activity let's say
during the mosquito season they will
communicate with the health officer and
request that the health officer provide
certain messaging to the community to
help them understand the risk and know
how to um take measures to protect
themselves so they're more of a
Communication channel for the state too
to reach local populations um and then
with rabies Health officers do have some
very limited authority to help with
containment of animals who have um
rabies thank you you're welcome
representative Edwards so uh that last
sentence of yours uh triggered a
question I I was holding off on and that
is as I'm looking at page two all the
bullet items with collaborate and
support
I I don't I don't see any um power words
like
enforce uh and it's and you just gave us
an example of how they have an
enforcement power are there other
enforcement Powers yes that's a great
question so Health officers really serve
a lot of roles and a lot of them is are
um mostly around transmitting messaging
for the state programs but enforcement
um Authority is given under RSA 147
which which is the public health
nuisance statute um and they are given
powers to enforce things like failed
septic systems so that um is an
authority that Dees uses very frequently
so Dees licenses um septic designs and
installations but if a septic system is
to fail the health officer is the
primary enforcement mechanism for those
types of situations so rather go to the
followup so rather than go to the
building inspector and have the other
Town's normal procedure for citing
issues this this individual has the
power to to do what exactly issue a
subpoena issue of citation issue you
what yes so for RSA 147 it's very
specific to Public Health nuisances is
what health officers can enforce and the
language is very specific around septic
system so a septic system is failed the
health officer can require that they
bring it back into a sanitary condition
so sometimes that's pumping sometimes
that's replacing the system um but they
can enforce the repair of that system
okay final comment yes uh okay so I
would just say that for a future report
given the Live Free or Die attitude in
New Hampshire and the people's concerns
about the state enforcing things it
would might be nice to clarify for uh in
the report what the limits um and extent
of the enforcement Authority is that's a
great idea thank you we will incorporate
that Senator gray um just a suggestion
for a future look okay um right now in
the education thing um because the way
the education statutes are a even a
small school has to have you know a
principal superintendent uh you know it
it appears to me that probably these
Health officers uh even if I'm talking
19 or 23 I'm talking around
8 to 10% of the communities in the
Hampshire that don't have a health
officer and if I open that up so that
the county could have a health
officer and then the community share it
uh but that would take legislation but
it would take a suggestion from Mr
Williams and yourselves um to get that
rolling uh you know somebody needs to
think and see if that's would be
advantageous uh to do that and and cost
savings to do that I think that is a
very very great question and suggestion
and I know that there are a few Regional
public health networks who have
approached us with interest of having a
health officer for their Public Health
Network so I think there is opportunity
to look at the current structure of this
local Health officer position and think
about maybe ways that would be more
efficient especially if they were at a
county level there might be opportunity
for full time and bring in someone who
has a background you know in
environmental health issues so I think
it's it's a great point and I'll bring
else singing no one thank you so much
thank
you did you entertain a motion I would
entertain a motion uh M Mr chair I'd
like to uh make a motion I I I move that
uh we place um representative Wayne
McDonald into nomination to be Vice
chair of this committee for the I think
that's next term excellent
suggestion we need to find out if
representative McDonald is willing to do
that I do accept the nomination thank
you
wonderful any other
nominations seeing none all in favor I
opposed thank you
I'll take next month off Mr chair yes um
there was an open item that uh I had
suggested to Mr Williams that didn't
make it on the agenda that may be worth
mention we do have time if you would
like to raise it to see if we can do
this okay so um it it happened that a a
blinding flash of the obvious uh hit me
the other day that um one of the things
that I I think all of the
representatives are asked to do on
occasion is to um support a constituent
request to follow up and find out what
the status of their situation is with
DHHS and I've been doing this for eight
years I've just sort of you know goofed
around and tried to get it into somebody
and it struck me that um I think it was
during one of Mr Williams other
presentations that um that the they're
all already set up and to some extent it
may be a really great extent to handle
individual cases from legislators and
others and feed it into a control system
so that they can
systematically pursue a followup and
make sure that the case was resolved
properly or if it wasn't that they could
go back and remediate gaps um it it
would be great if we could as an element
of over site maybe get um a monthly
report a quarterly report an annual
report that just tells us the numbers
how many of these constituent cases have
they had to process um and and and to
the extent that there are any uh Sops
standard operating procedures on how to
send the information to a particular
person in in DHHS and know that you're
going to get an answer back someday that
this was okay this this wasn't quite
okay and we fixed it you know just some
sort of feedback so so I I I I think Mr
Williams may be able to tell us a lot
about a system that exists that I never
knew about
formally so great or or Miss Tilly thank
you I I got the Short Straw today so
because I stayed late so thank you so
much again Patricia Tilly associate
commissioner at the department um so
thank you for this question and I think
you're asking important things um the
first thing that I would say just for
the immediate ask I know that uh there
were some uh needy clarification about
so if I have a problem today who do I
contact at the at the department the
easiest answer for you to do on this
list there's Kathy Capron it says
scheduling for associate Commissioners
Kathy is your go-to she handles all of
the constituent concerns from the
governor's office and then she routes
them once they get to the department she
will always be able to Route it to the
right person or find the right person
through one of us to get the question to
so that's the immediate request we can
take care of that so send stuff to Kathy
right there um and Kathy with an ie if
you want to really make her happy and
make sure you spell it right so I didn't
I I wasn't ready when you said it where
where on the page so on this page where
it says scheduling for associate
Commissioners that Kathy Capron right
there outstanding she's your go-to lady
she will take care of you the bigger
question you're asking around how can we
capture this in a more systemic way is
is very interesting we know that the
governor's office um under Governor
snono built in a new constituent um
relationship sort of database or process
where they can manage some of those
inquiries it's based off of our own
Salesforce um platform that you're well
aware of which we we'd like to remind
them that we paid for but we it is a
great system to start with we are
investigating how we can um Not
Duplicate but sort of enhance that
moving forward it's not ready yet but
it's certainly something that we're
interested in because you're right we're
all chasing down um concerns because not
only is Kathy the right person to go to
we know that all of you have
relationships with some of us at the
department that you've been successful
with and you know that we'll get it to
the right person as well so that's the
long-term Vision we're not quite there
yet um but that's where we would like to
be distinguish that please from me
calling John Williams on the weekend oh
no wait a minute um there's there is the
Ombudsman Jennifer Jones and there's
also something I've been given these
things for nine years I don't think I
ever noticed the one on the bottom left
where it said Client Services would you
distinguish those you want to talk a
little bit
about okay um as it as it relates to my
relationship with the uh members of the
legislature I I look amongst the
committee and I think represent Woods
you're the only person I have not worked
with directly in constituent um
inquiries that come through and I do
receive them not only from the um State
Legislature but also from our
Congressional Delegation that sometimes
will reach out to me as well and I am
good at getting people linked up but
what Trisha what associate commissioner
Tilly is explaining that we already have
a built-in process in place and we're
we're getting to metrics which was what
um represent Edwards was getting at
that's where the repository coming to
Kathy allows us the opportunity to give
you the number of um referrals that have
come in perhaps even broken down by
which program areas or program areas
multiple uh were involved with
addressing those issues when I receive
your email phone call whatever I just do
my best to try to be a problem solver
working with you and working with those
problem solvers within the department
and I just my goal is to to get you to
the right people or your constituent to
getting their problem looked at
meaningfully and and perhaps resolved so
um that's something that I've been doing
with you folks for well over a decade
plus but there is this other process
that's already built in and if you're
looking for the type of information that
Miss Tilly direct excuse me associate
Commissioners Bo that's going way back
call me Trish um in time that that is
that is the ideal process if you're
looking to getting the metrics that
represent Edwards was was referring to
but I will say I do enjoy working with
you and I enjoy troubleshooting and but
if you want to keep it into the system
for data purposes uh that as described
by Comm absolutely and I think all of us
are always available to anyone to answer
any questions so we want to make sure
that we're not closing a door there but
we can um Kathy's a great person to just
send it to and you know it's off your
plate and we can get it organized to
where it needs to go that your note
around you see Client Services elsewhere
this is where it's complex because many
of our divisions clearly have client
facing roles where they address client
concerns um Even in our division for
children youth and family we have some
con a new new role which is really
around constituent inquiries and so
that's what we need to organize on our
end to think about as a department level
how do we sort through all that because
we're already figuring it out at a
division level we need to bring that up
and sort of have a big picture at the
department my followup is uh could you
give me the information so I can put it
here under dcyf who that uh person
Fielding things from the public is I
I'll forward you her um email address
I'll forward it to the group I'll
forward it to you and the group and a
followup to my first question was uh
what is the role then of the Ombudsman
in
this take the you're the lawyer so the
ombudsman's office there's actually two
distinct different types of Ombudsman
within our agency just for clarity we
have the office of long-term care um
budsman that deals with uh in
individuals who are residents in
long-term care facility setting and Su
buckon is our long-term care um budsman
we had a similar um discussion before uh
chairman McDonald's committee uh when we
did our our speed meet and greet
orientation on this very subject that
was also attended by division three in
addition to that we have Jennifer Jones
she is an attorney by background um and
she is the Department's um budsman under
statute they do fall under the umbrella
of the department she does report uh to
our chief legal officer Melissa Saint
Seer however under statute they are
independent in terms of their actions
because they're enabled to help
individuals navigate through the process
with with their concerns um they serve
an incredibly important function with
the within the agency but as as
identified there are other um Solutions
also to trying to addressing individuals
um concerns or problems um so we try to
have as many doors open um my door is
open associate commissioner uh Tilly's
door is open and so is Jennifer Jones
and trying to get to the right place if
I would say just from a highlevel um
Viewpoint of the EMB budsman they tend
to get involved with uh matters that
were other um resources within the
department they may not be satisfied
with necessarily the answer so they go
to the um budman's office to get an
independent person to help sort out so I
I I believe they they are involved with
much more complex issues uh at at that
point in time because they are looking
for additional followup based upon
information provided earlier by the
department whether it's for eligibility
for services or benefits and and that's
where um uh
uh Jones as the um budsman serves a
really important function within the
office to have that independent Voice
who understands the department but also
can act independently to look into those
individuals uh concerns uh also in
addition to that we have our
administrative Appeals Unit which also
falls under the umbrella of the
department that are independent and they
will take appeals for denials of
services and benefits from the
Department denial period uh the um
period for filing for an appeal is 30
days from whatever administrative action
uh and I'm just giving you that for a
more complete picture of what falls
under uh Melissa saints's umbrella as it
relates to addressing individual
constituents
concerns that's a lot of the
representative Edwards so so this
followup is kind of mostly for you Mr
chair um is this a topic that you would
like to have the oversight committee
request the department to periodically
report back on a summary basis on the
kind of volume
and results they're
getting yeah I think so I think that
would be able to help me when somebody
says you know they don't just listen and
and I want to be able to say hey wait a
minute in the last three months alone
there were
569 serious queries that they had dealt
with and gotten back to people on that
so it would be a good thing it would uh
help me as I tell people what a great
DHHS we have yeah I think that'd be
goodes and then as a followup to that
followup the the other part of that
question is what sort of frequency are
you thinking I I I I I would I would not
want to ask them to do it very
frequently because this is going to be
new work new process clean up I mean for
them to actually do this right and want
to report on it probably it's going to
take six months for them to figure it
out right so I was thinking our June
meeting maybe we can give you uh by June
we can give you an update on our process
I you know hopefully we'll have some
anecdotal information by then I don't
want to say that by June we will have a
full picture because I think we need to
Define it of what's an inquiry what's
not an inquiry what's just someone
following up on their um their case you
know so I think we have some thinking to
do about that but we can certainly give
you an update in June about where we are
I also think a flowchart saying initial
number to call sounds like Kathy kapron
and if it's really in your opinion not
really going anywhere then there is an
OB Ombudsman for appeal and then if it
really hit the wall you've got the
administrative Appeals Unit or something
just a little flowchart so people don't
call at the wrong level or feel like
there's only one bite of the apple and
if that doesn't work they're dead that
would be helpful for me as I route
people okay otherwise I'll just call
John yes representative Weber
and I just want to express my concern
with everything I've just heard because
my experience is that when I have a
constituent concern or when others have
a constituent concern and they consult
me and this is all for
legislators either I know the person
that they need to talk to or I know that
John knows the person that I need to
talk to and I have never had an
appropriate response take more than 24
hours on any issue no matter how
complex and if I have to have a chart of
whom to call and then whom to call and
then I have to wait and then I have to
go somewhere else that is going to
result in significantly less Nimble
constituent response than what is
happening regularly now and for which I
am eternally grateful and my
constituents are eternally grateful
because some of them were in very
difficult circumstances and needed a
response within 2 24 hours uh but I I I
also think that we need to be very
careful with the reporting requirements
because if every time I make a phone
call somebody has to sit down and make a
report and send it to their supervisor
to be sent to their supervisor to be
sent to the reporter data data entry
people I think we're creating a
nightmare to solve a problem that
doesn't exist and I just wanted to be
sure that I got that on the
record except for that very last bit I
would wholeheartly
agree um I have made use of these cards
ever since I got them them and uh if I
don't know what to do because there are
obviously units in here that aren't
printed out I do call attorney Williams
I'm responding I'm jumping in on this
because now we were told about Kathy
kapron and and um maybe I am hearing it
being made more complex than was said
and if that's the case I apologize for
that and representative um uh Weber I
would wholeheartedly agree with your
experience has been my experience
representative
Edwards I I I I want a Nimble uh
responsive system the the experience
that representative Weber uh gets I'm
sure has is somewhat a function of her
experience her judgment her wisdom her
you knowledge of who does what but I'm
reminded that we have a a third of the
house turnover every two years we all
have constituents we're all sort of
confused the first couple of terms and
if there was a simple way without
breaking the good stuff that we have to
help the new kids be able to support
their constituents or at least be told
how to do it I think that would be good
and the summary report once a year or
whatever that says something to the
effect that you know uh we we have we've
had X
number of inquiries through this uh
constituent service and uh 89% of them
were revealed to to be handled properly
to begin with and the other 11% we
resolved I mean I'm not looking for any
personal data I just want to know did we
do it right or did we figure out we
needed to do something slightly
different I don't want to get involved
in the case I don't want to get involved
in the investigation I just want to know
that I've done my job to communicate
effectively and that the grown-ups are
looking into
it I get almost no constituent concerns
because I'm in a floal and they know the
individual who lives in their Town what
I get is constituent concerns secondhand
from lots of Representatives hey who do
you know over there who it usually
starts off with and not only do I have
it on the card I know most these people
so that's what I do if I don't have to
call
you anything else representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman I think I
know the answer to this question but I
have to ask it I just because I get
asked it um the number one thing I
people call me about whether it's a
constituent or another legislator or a
person from outside of my district the
number one question I usually get is I
was turned down for benefits that's how
the conversation start
and I said well did you get a I assume
they still get a notice of decision
whether it's email or regular mail and
that's the first question I said I I'll
ask them well did you get a notice of
decision well what's that I said well
you're not just turned down you have to
be given an explanation it's usually
very clearly indicated on there uh
whether it's on report you know your
income is over whether you know you
didn't Supply the proper information or
they need addition something additional
so that that process has not changed
with you folks then I assume that is
correct okay thank
you representative Weber and for a
followup at that point there is a 30-day
appeals period where they can appeal to
correct anyone else would you share some
of the exciting things we're going to be
participating in next
month well if I happen to have the draft
agenda in front of me which I do not you
back so chairman McDonald's members of
the committee it's wonderful
organizational meeting I will say for
the record since I've been working with
this group this is the the earliest I've
ever seen an organ organizational
meeting happened uh so congratulations
on achieving The Impossible um your next
meeting uh a regular meeting which will
be struck because it was not going to be
an organizational meeting because you
have enough members today to vote in
your officers uh that um on the tenative
agenda is the uh commissioner's update
um which you'll be receiving for for
next month uh put it in perspective
we're going to be right after division 3
is getting started Full Tilt and so I'm
sure there's going to be lots of
communications and probably discussions
around that whole process uh we have the
rare disease advisory Council that is
slated you had um represent Nagel whose
name is spelled correctly at least on
the draft agenda here uh for um his
report for 15 minutes and he will be
getting some Outreach typically if it's
news to people we we don't normally do
what you're asking me to do uh but I
reach out to them make sure that they
are available and I'll start lining up
folks so these are tentative at at this
point subject to being moved to your
March meeting which is now the standing
um meeting date uh is on the fourth
Friday of the month at one o'clock um
unless there is a major holiday that
would make it necessitating to having it
on the third Friday of a month um in
addition to that we have the
subcommittee on Alzheimer's disease and
related dementia uh you have Jen Jenny
Horan who you know from the Senate who
is now with the Alzheimer's Association
who is doing a great job the chair of
that committee is uh Senator avard so
he'll be participating in that process
um and they'll give their annual update
um there are um updates that stem from
the last hb2 from Henry liman as it
relates to uh post um natal care um and
he'll be giving that quarterly report uh
Michael Holt he is on for the
therapeutic cannabits today he just got
through the public hearings uh before uh
chairman McDonald's committee uh just on
Wednesday of this week uh therapeutic
cannabis day in front of your committee
uh and then he'll be providing his
annual update uh around that and then
the uh therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board also has its separate
report um as well in former
representative Jerry kerk um serves as
the chair and I would imagine you'll see
your alumnist come back before this
committee along with Mike hle uh we have
the M maternal mortality uh review this
is more likely going to be on your March
agenda um but that's uh slated as well
as the 2024 State fiscal year uh child
fatality Review Committee so you can see
we have a very robust agenda coming up
for February and uh the date right now
is tentatively set for um Friday um
Friday February 21st um at 1 in the
determined if you would like to make it
the 28th we will change it on the Fly
Right Now whatever the fourth Friday of
the month is isn't it okay I don't have
the calendar in front of me and I did
the best that I could the Senate will be
on
break during are all on school break
right thank you February vacation
Senator rosemal thank you that is why I
moved it to the 21st realizing the
Senate was going to be on break thank
you for refreshing my recollection smart
yeah thank you
great we are finished thank you and we